bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 7
juin voici les titres de ce journal
l'événement rassemble tous les acteurs
du numérique autour des filiales
industrielles dans un contexte où la
menace cyber est de plus en plus
présente là paris seiver week se déroule
demain et mercredi à la maison de la
chimie à paris sébastien garneau
organisateurs de l'événement sera avec
nous nous irons également dans les
locaux d'atos aux clayes-sous-bois
engagés dans la cybersécurité une année
de travail en classe autour de la danse
c'est le principe du projet danse à
l'école qui se déroule depuis 22 ans
maintenant dans les établissements du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
ce week-end les élèves ont présenté
leurs chorégraphies et puis immersion au
sein des coulisses d'un court métrage le
réalisateur nadira you lie in étaient
présents dans sa ville la verrière pour
le tournage de cette oeuvre en réalité
virtuelle et dans le premier rôle aziz
diabaté connu pour avoir joué dans
plusieurs séries télévisées et nous
parlerons tout à l'heure de la 18e
édition des rendez vous aux jardins qui
se sont tenues elle s'est tenue cette
édition ce week-end et notamment à saint
quentin en yvelines
mais avant de développer ces titres le
déconfinement qui entre dans une
nouvelle phase cette semaine sept
cette semaine ce mercredi l'étape 3 sera
déclenchée avec une levée des
restrictions liées à la pandémie de kobe
19 le couvre feu passera de 21h à 23h
les cafés restaurants pourront rouvrir
leurs salles intérieures avec une jauge
de 50% et un maximum de six personnes à
table elle les terrasses pourront
repasser en pleine capacité
réouverture également des salles de
sport des salons et d'efforts
d'exposition avec une jauge à chaque
fois et un protocole enfin l'accueil des
touristes étrangers se fera sur
présentation du fameux pass sanitaire
également la fin du télétravail
systématique dans les entreprises
prochaine étape et dernière étape le 30
juin avec la levée finale des
restrictions nouvelle étape qui
intervient dans un contexte où les
indicateurs de kobe 19 sont tous à la
baisse c'est le cas dans le département
des yvelines sur une semaine le taux
d'incidence est à dire le nombre de
nouveaux contaminés sur 100000 habitants
est repassé sous la barre des 107 une
première
depuis le mois de décembre taux de
positivité à 2,7 pour cent
la tension continue de se desserrer à
l'hôpital de 190 personnes étaient
hospitalisées hier sur le territoire
illinois - quarante et une en une
semaine
soixante de patients étaient toujours en
réanimation et depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire 1815 personnes sont
décédées du colis de 19 dans les
hôpitaux du département
je vous en parlais dans les titres la
troisième édition de la paris games week
se tient ce mardi 8 et mercredi 9 juin
c'est à la maison de la chimie à paris
un événement auquel est associé
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines comme partenaire et pour en
parler
sébastien garneau est avec nous bonsoir
ans à par visioconférence vous êtes le
fondateur est l'organisateur de cet
événement qui a pour vocation de
rassembler tous les acteurs du numérique
autour des filières industrielles dans
un contexte je le disais dans les titres
ou les la menace les cyber attaques
augmentent sont très présentes
l'objectif c'est d'unir les forces et
des aussi les décideurs publics privés a
à faire face justement ces
problématiques
c'est exactement ça effectivement on est
à la troisième édition est tout
l'intérêt de mettre au même endroit au
même moment sur les mêmes sujets à la
fois décideurs publics et décideurs
privés
ça permet de faire monter l'ensemble en
compétences et vous citiez saint quentin
comme partenaire et c'est même un
partenaire fondateur est donc pour nous
c'est une joie de les avoir à nouveau
cette année on va recevoir des députés
on va recevoir des agents publics on va
recevoir des chefs d'entreprise et
ensemble en croisant des expertises
c'est comme ça qu'on va réussir à lutter
contre contre un fléau qui s'est
accélérée avec le confinement on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler tout à l'heure
pourquoi justement faut-il aider ces
décideurs et skull se retrouvent
aujourd'hui et démunis face à ces
problématiques les cyberattaques ces
attaques aux roches noires c'est ces
logiciels qui en quelques s'en prennent
en otage les données ils se retrouvent
démunis aujourd'hui ses acteurs
clairement ils sont démunis pour pour
moins trois raisons la première c'est
qu'il ya un manque de connaissance du
sujet donc c'est important de faire de
la communication
le deuxième c'est qu'il ya un manque de
compétences parce que face à la fracture
numérique en fait on est tous victimes
on sait utiliser un smartphone mais
entre utiliser un smartphone et savoir
ce qui se passe derrière le smartphone
il ya un petit iota et puis après il ya
la question budgétaire
je pense notamment aux décideurs publics
mais aussi aux pme en période de crise
sanitaire on voit que les budgets sont
pas forcément très très extensible et
donc du coup quand vous mettez ces trois
problèmes les uns à côté des autres
eh bien vous ne pouvez pas faire face à
la chanson white la meilleure réponse
face à cela c'est justement de créer une
communauté d'experts sur ce sujet alors
je vais casser notre conviction on pense
que comme chacun une partie de
l'expertisé de l'expérience quand
rassembler on croise les expériences
qu'il ya toujours des solutions
c'est peut-être un des enseignements
d'ailleurs du confinement c'est que même
si les outils numériques nous permettent
de poursuivre notre activité on a quand
même besoin d'être en contact les uns
avec les autres
selon land si l' agence nationale de la
sécurité des systèmes d'information le
nombre de cyberattaques a été multipliée
par 4 en 2020 et dans les yvelines
plusieurs collectivités en ont fait les
frais en 2021 la ville de houilles aussi
celle des l'encours comment faire face à
ces menaces de plus en plus nombreuses
un point global sur la cybersécurité
avec le groupe atos qui est implanté aux
clayes-sous-bois la cybersécurité se
trouve au coeur des activités d'atos
l'entreprise dispose d'un datacenter aux
clayes-sous-bois le but de l'acteur du
numérique protéger les données des
entreprises et collectivités face à des
menaces informatiques de plus en plus
évoluer les moyens mis en oeuvre par les
pirates et par les hackers sont de plus
en plus important et puis il ya une
globalisation de cette connaissance là
si on veut pouvoir se protéger il faut
utiliser les meilleurs outils avec les
meilleures équipes qui ont ses
compétences et ses connaissances
pour se faire atos propose des produits
des logiciels par exemple permettent de
protéger l'identité les communications
ou encore encoder les données d'autres
services sont proposés
on va pouvoir gérer pour le compte d'une
entreprise l'intégralité de son
patrimoine de données on va pouvoir
gérer aussi ce qu'on appelle ses centres
opérationnels de sécurité
le apporter un système de bouclier de
protection face aux attaques cyber dont
elle peut être victime
aujourd'hui le domaine manque de
compétences en europe c'est un manque de
300 mille experts en cybersécurité qui a
été recensé pour pallier cette
problématique l'entreprise s'associe à
des universitaires et des laboratoires
de recherche
on va par exemple dans leurs produits
intégrés des recherches et
développements qui sont faits par des
universitaires ou par des laboratoires
de recherche ou d'éco conception que
l'on fait avec nos clients
en fait avec ça on va gagner en
efficacité en vitesse et puis on va
adapter nos solutions directement au cad
usages clients une école dédiée à la
cybersécurité où ira à saint quentin en
yvelines en septembre prochain selon lan
si le nombre de cyber attaques a été
multipliée par 4 en 2020 et avec moi
toujours par visioconférence sébastien
garneau fondateur et organisateur de la
paris seiver wii qui se déroule la
troisième édition ce mardi et mercredi à
paris
je le disais tout à l'heure des
cyberattaques qui ont été multipliées
par 4 il ya même d'autres sources qui
affirment qu'elles ont été multipliées
par cinq
comment peut-on expliquer justement ces
augmentations par plusieurs raisons mais
de toute façon par quatre par 5
on n'a pas besoin de compter les gouttes
pour savoir qui pleut donc la question
c'est comment on se protège de cette
vague de cette pluie on voit notamment
que sur la question des collectivités
vous citiez la ville de houilles il ya
il ya des acteurs de terrain notamment
au xi boc je voudrais citer parce qu'on
ne parle d' atos qui est un très très
grand groupe et et qui accompagne de
nombreux aux prises mais il ya aussi à
saint-quentin tout un maillage de pme et
notamment qui était aux côtés de deux
oui comment on fait pour se protéger il
faut prendre conscience et comment on
fait pour prendre conscience il faut en
parler et c'est pour ça que paris
célèbre os x est un événement qui se
tient bien sûr en ligne mais aussi anti
en présentiel et après il faut aller sur
le terrain mobiliser à la fois les
maires et dirigeants de thèmes et vous
le disiez tout à l'heure c'est un sujet
qui est sur la table depuis quelques
années maintenant mais qui a été on va
dire remis vraiment
du jour qui a été accentuée avec les
effets du confinement et du télétravail
il disait ça a eu un effet justement sur
l'herbe sur cette thématique est ce qui
s'est passé pendant le télétravail on a
tous basculé chez donc il a fallu ouvrir
les réseaux d'entreprise pour permettre
aux collaborateurs de ce pouvoir
connecter aux fichiers clients officier
à la base de prospects ces fichiers
comptables notamment en faisant ça on a
baissé la garde et aujourd'hui la
sécurité s'est jamais le premier la
première porte d'entrée la première
porte d'entrée d'une entreprise c'est le
business
donc il fallait assurer la continuité
des affaires et en faisant ça on sait on
s'est exposé on a élargi ce qu'on
appelle la surface d'attac il ya plus
d'entreprises qui sont exposés et puis
par ailleurs il ya un autre problème
c'est que les collaborateurs n'ont pas
les compétences parce qu'ils sont pas
assez formés
vous citiez une école qui va ouvrir à
saint-quentin je crois que c'est l'école
de 1600 et une super une super
initiative puisse être formé justement
c'est la base c'est vrai c'est vrai pour
les collaborateurs mais c'est vrai aussi
pour les décideurs et ça c'est ce qu'on
essaie de nous de porter c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui si vous allez voir un
député il n'est pas certain qu'il ait
une vraie connaissance et c'est bien
normal d enjeu sauf qu'il est hyper
exposé lui même ses équipes et il a des
informations sensibles la sensibilité
des informations d'un député c'est les
mêmes pour le chef d'entreprise sont
chez son fichier clients il n'a pas de
prix et il ya des stats qui couvrent et
parmi les stades qui courent il ya qu'
une entreprise qui se fait à quai la
plupart du temps 80% du temps elles
ferment ce options de l'emploi et tout
ça c'est derrière tout ça c'est les
compétences donc c'est un enjeu qui est
pris de plus en plus en considération
notamment sur des territoires et
collectivités comme saint quentin en
yvelines ya des grands groupes il ya des
pme qui travaillent sur la cybersécurité
vous citiez aussi l'école de 1601 qui va
ouvrir en septembre sur le territoire
saint quentinois
revenons justement à votre événement là
paris cyber wii qui est au programme je
le disais la maison de la chimie en
présentiel juste déjà c'est important
aussi le propose en présentiel on sait
que de nom
heureux événement ont soit été annulés
soit reportée soit proposée en visio de
le proposer justement physique c'était
quelque chose d'important pour vous
c'est même une conviction
on a cette chance d'avoir été le dernier
événement de 2020 en présentiel et on a
cet honneur d'être le premier cette
année en france et à ma connaissance en
europe pourquoi c'est important parce
que s'ils numérique nous permet bien sûr
de communiquer tout le monde vous dira
que c'est pas pareil quand je vois parce
que autour d'un café
on est en train de voir finalement son
partenaire et puis de l'autre côté on va
voir une autre personne et est
concrètement d'être ensemble au même
endroit pour nous ça fait partie de la
solution
le numérique ne règle pas tout permet
d'aller plus vite nous permet de faire
mieux il permet de faire plus fort mais
ils ne remplacent pas les changes
d'informations entre les uns et les
autres êtres en présentiel
c'est aussi une forme de résilience
parce que parce qu'on va pas rester
enfermé à vie et donc il faut aussi
apprendre à faire des événements
professionnels dans des conditions qui
ne sont pas idéales ne sont pas celles
d'avant mais c'est comme le risque cyber
il faut regarder le risque le maîtriser
prendre des contre-mesures et assurer la
sécurité collective dernière question
très rapide parce qu'on arrive à la fin
de cet entretien quel est l'essentiel du
programme à retenir de cette part is
either way cette troisième édition
parmi les temps forts j'en citerai au
moins au moins quatre peut-être sur la
souveraineté technologique parce que il
ya bien sûr une question de dépendance
du numérique et de la cyber et là on est
sur un danger plus tôt géostratégique
il ya aussi un moment fort ce qui
concerne la transition énergétique
aujourd'hui on oppose transition
numérique et transition énergétique
or ce sont deux mouvements qui vont
ensemble et qu'on doit articuler
ensemble et bien sûr l'intervention de
la ministre des armées puis
l'intervention du ministre de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères et enfin
peut-être les prix grandes priorités de
la présidence française de l'union
européenne la france prend la tête de
l'europe dans six mois elle était
important pour nous comme nous sommes un
événement européen de faire un peu de
teasing de cette présidence en montrant
tous
tout ce qu'on pense et tout ce qu'on
essaie de faire
ensemble un événement qui sera à suivre
en live sur le réseau linkedin merci
sébastien garneau d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous elle vient de rappel vous
êtes le fondateur est l'organisateur de
cette parisse à berwick la direction
trappe à présent où est organisé ce
week-end son rendez-vous à l'initiative
de plusieurs partis politiques de gauche
d'associations et de syndicats les 150
ans de la commune de paris ont été
commémorés le 18 mars 1871 les parisiens
se révolte contre le gouvernement et
mettre en place un gouvernement du
peuple
l'épisode est court et durera 72 jours
avant de se terminer par la semaine
sanglante ou 20000 communards furent
tués est depuis deux semaines une
exposition sur l'histoire de la commune
étaient proposés dans le hall de la
mairie de trappes jusqu'au 16 juin
désormais c'est une exposition sur la
place des femmes qui est proposé pendant
cette période et samedi il y avait aussi
des projections une conférence et des
débats qui ont eu lieu au conservatoire
de musique et de danse pour parler
notamment de l'héritage de la commune
elle les propos recueillis par eléonore
sinoquet elle met en avant ce que ce que
la la république va créer par la suite
un jules ferry se targue de créer
d'avoir créé là l'école publique non
elle a été fait déjà pendant la commune
pareil pour la laïcité un les femmes en
participer pleinement à la vie
puisqu'elle est il ya eu des écoles pour
femmes y compris dans leur dimension
professionnelle professionnelles elles
ont participé à la vie publique comme
comme les hommes sur l'éducation la
culture le travail
une multitude de décrit justement c'est
des choses qui nous restent même si
certaines ont été bafoués remis en cause
il ya un fondement qui reste quand même
22 ans d'existence désormais pour le
projet danse à l'école sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines ce week-end
les élèves de l'agglomération ont montré
leur famille le travail d'une année
autour de la danse était à la
commanderie à elancourt est le reportage
de mélanie poquet aider les honneurs
sinoquet comme tout bon danseur
j'invite toutes les personnes qui sont
là hein ma compagnie dans un petit essai
de corps agathe fauves adèle vous fait
entrer dans la danse pour la sixième
année consécutive la chorégraphe
coordonne danse à l'école
une nouvelle édition à la saveur toute
particulière
le candidat tout transformer mais après
on n'a jamais lâché
en partenariat avec dow avec linda on a
toujours on a été on était convaincus du
fait que ça soit essentiel que cette
aventure existe et aille au bout d'une
manière ou d'une autre
pendant deux jours les participants ont
fait découvrir à leur famille le travail
d'une année quatorze classes de la
maternelle au lycée sur toute
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est un bonheur de voir des enfants de
tous âges dansent et se retrouvent et
surtout prendre du plaisir un moment où
on sort d'une pandémie où on a fait un
classement entre l'essentiel et non
essentiels la participation de ses
enfants et de leurs familles montre à
quel point il est essentiel de continuer
à avoir une vie qui ne soit pas
exclusivement tournée vers les besoins
vitaux mais aussi vers la culture vers
le bonheur de se retrouver développer
son autonomie vaincre sa timidité danse
à l'école existe depuis 22 ans en
partenariat avec l'éducation nationale
culture toujours adrénaline c'est le nom
du dernier court métrage du réalisateur
de la verrière de la verrière un nadir
yulin cette fiction d'une vingtaine de
minutes on est en réalité virtuelle
parle de la vie dans les quartiers et
plus généralement sur le cros bitume
célia gars tsongo s'est rendu sur le
tournage dernier jour de tournage pour
l'équipe du film adrénaline le
réalisateur nadir you lie in originaire
de la verrière réalise son quatrième
projet un court métrage qui emmène les
spectateurs dans les quartiers ce matin
là les séquences en motocross sont
filmés en réalité virtuelle 360
quand vous mettez un casque et que vous
retrouvé immergé dans un univers était -
vous êtes le même personnage c'est une
expérience tout le court métrage eux
seraient en réalité virtuelle pour la
captation il utilise une caméra en 8k
avec six objectifs
le but pour le réalisateur aux mélanges
et la réalité virtuelle en 360 avec les
histoires du monde urbain dans le
premier rôle
aziz diabaté connu pour avoir joué dans
les séries télévisées les brass les
rouges et ici tout commence à me donne à
dire hugh lane il a tout de suite
accepté le rôle de azzedine mon
personnage il est un peu comme moi trop
la bécane il y bien dans sa vie kiffe
les gens c'est pas un vicieux et les
gentils et en gros de valeur et vinh
galère parce qu elle a acheté bah en
fait à partir d'autres mecs et le dha
qu'il achetait bas en fait il la voulait
et voilà comment commence histoire sur
le tournage beaucoup de jeunes des cités
avoisinantes étaient autorisés à venir
voir les scènes et certains ont même
participé dans le but d'initier les
jeunes aux métiers de l'imagerie
numérique et du cinéma
tous les jeunes à qui ont participé du
bois de l'étang du val hibou d'elancourt
ils découvrent ces métiers là learning
by doing il les découvre
invivo s'il n'y a pas trop de théorie en
fait ils viennent poser la question à
comment on fait si comment on fait ça et
le voyons pratiques y voit comment on
doit cacher un micro pourquoi on doit
cacher le fait de jouer un rôle faire
paraître quelque chose quelque chose de
faux tout est intéressant
franchement ton bled le court métrage
devrait être sorti début juillet est
proposé dans différents festivals
vous avez eu quelques problèmes
techniques mais vous pourrez retrouver
ce reportage en replay 1 sur notre site
internet tv 78 points comme on referme
ce journal au jardin ce week-end c'était
la 18e édition des rendez vous aux
jardins l'objectif sensibiliser et faire
découvrir leur diversité leur richesse à
cette occasion la toute nouvelle
pépinière de villepreux s'ouvrait pour
une balade et découverte avec bérengère
bourgoin et bixente n'ai rien senti
steban on peut se poser s'asseoir
discuter sous l'arbre l'arbre devient un
signal dans le paysage les rendez vous
aux jardins à saint quentin en yvelines
se sont ouverts vendredi dernier par une
visite guidée du parc forestier de la
pépinière à villepreux l'architecte
paysagiste responsable de cet espace
était présent l'idée c'était de vraiment
deux de retrouvés
la mémoire du site qui est une ancienne
pépinière de s'approprier cet espace là
et cette culture là pour redessiner un
réseau de parcours de promenade pour
redorer ouvrir le milieu pour pour créer
des milieux de vie
pendant deux heures les participants ont
re découvert un espace qu'ils traversent
quotidiennement
ils étaient une quinzaine à avoir pu
s'inscrire à cette visite également
organisées dans le cadre de la semaine
ville proviennent du développement
durable c'est rare je pense de pouvoir
dialoguer en direct avec le concepteur
même d'un tel espace comme on dire
naturel et forestier donc les les
visiteurs étaient étaient très curieux
et très demandeur d'informations cette
visite a permis de recueillir le
ressenti des promeneurs du parc
les participants ont donné leur avis on
ne l'a pas fait au pas de charge
ça c'était agréable et puis j'ai appris
plein de choses
et en plus il y avait une écoute enfin
c'est aussi très agréable ce que j'ai pu
poser des questions pour faire des
petites réflexions et ça a été rude bien
reçu les rendez vous aux jardins se sont
poursuivies ce week-end dans l'ensemble
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi très belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]